- Hi, good afternoon, everyone.
Welcome.
My name is Priya Natarajan,
I'm the current director
of The Franke Program in Science
and the Humanities at Yale,
our flagship interdisciplinary program.
I am delighted to invite you all back
to today's discussion session following
a fantastic Colloquium yesterday,
given by Professor Brian Cantwell Smith.
The title of his colloquium
was "Inference in a Non-Conceptual World."
And as part of the Nature
of Inference Series,
it has been our practice
to follow-up the Colloquium
by a distinguished
speaker with a discussion
and with a conversant,
a distinguished researcher,
who might have a slightly
different perspective
from the Colloquium
speaker the previous day.
And it is my absolute honor today
to invite Professor Joseph Rouse
from Wesleyan University
to be the conversant and
lead discussant today.
Professor Rouse's primary
research interests
are in the philosophy of science,
and the history of 20th
century philosophy,
interdisciplinary science studies,
and the social theory of practices.
Within these areas, his
primary foci include
the philosophy of scientific practice,
naturalism and anti-naturalism
in 20th century philosophy,
the metaphysics of normativity,
the connections between the analytic
and continental philosophy,
the relation of philosophy of science
to philosophy of mind and language,
and to metaphysics,
cultural studies of science
and feminist science studies.
He has many,
he's authored many books
and he has a current
manuscript under review,
"Social Practices as
Biological Niche Construction"
and in which he shows how and why
to integrate our biological conception
of human beings as animals
and our social cultural and
psychological conceptions
of human beings as persons
and acculturate agents.
So it is a real,
it's gonna be a real treat today
to witness this discussion,
interaction, and conversation.
And as per custom,
I'd like to invite you
all to post your questions
in the Q and A feature of the webinar.
And before I turn over the
floor to Professor Rouse,
I would just like to,
once again thank the support
from Mr. and Mrs. Richard
and Barbara Franke,
as well as the Templeton Foundation
that have made possible
this Inference Series.
And I also want to remind you
that we are recording this,
and therefore, all
participants are required
to mute their audio and videos.
So welcome once again, everyone.
And, Professor Rouse, the floor is yours.
Thank you so much to both of you
and, Brian, for you to come back again
to participate in this discussion.
- Okay, well, let me
begin by sharing my screen
and then by first thanking Ty Kamp
and Priya Natarajan for the invitation,
The Franke Center for the sponsorship,
and especially, Brian Cantwell Smith,
for his very rich and provocative talk.
Has taken on the fraught domain
of the relation between
thought and or language
and perception in action.
And with it, the demarcation
of conceptual content
from whatever is Non-Conceptual.
As he notes in the case
of Evanson McDowell,
disagreements in this domain often turn
on differing intuitions about,
or conceptions of what is
conceptual or non-conceptual
with proponents then
talking through one another.
And one constant difficulty
is to secure non-question
begging characterizations
of what we're talking about.
Brian and I also differ in some respects
in the end about what
is or is not conceptual,
but I'm confident we can avoid
such unproductive failures.
So, I'm gonna quickly overview
the themes of the talk.
And first, I'm gonna talk
about four central aspects
of Brian's talk, with which
I'm largely in agreement.
First, what he calls an ontological,
rather than an epistemic
understanding of the conceptual
& "non-conceptual" content distinction.
Second, his emphasis on
the fine-grained richness
& continuity of the world,
within which conceptual
understanding is situated
and to which it is accountable.
Third, we agree on many
of the key features
of conceptual understanding,
and I'll talk more about that shortly.
And finally, concerning the
constitutive normativity
of the conceptual domain,
which he, in the end,
understands in terms of the inseparability
of matter and mattering.
So I'm gonna go through
those four themes first,
but then I'm going to raise
four primary questions
in response to Brian's talk.
First, I wanna pick up on the question
of whether his initial
characterization of a feature-space
is the right way to think about
the phenomena he's talking about.
Second, I'm gonna ask a
question about whether the world
that we inhabit is in the non-conceptual,
given the pervasive involvement
of conceptual practices,
languages, imagery, equipment, music,
and so forth, in the world.
Third, I'm going to look a little harder
at Brian's conception of the conceptual,
oh, and ask whether instead of starting
from the kinds of conceptual structures
that say, someone like,
Evans, is talking about.
Whether we should talk start
from "conceptuality in the wild,"
much as Brian's work on computation,
suggests we start with conceptual,
with computation in the wild.
And finally, I wanna
ask a little bit about
the place of other agents
in the world we inhabit
and their bearing on the framing
and grounding of conceptual normativity.
So, first theme,
in Brian's ontological
account of intentionality
& contentfulness.
As most accounts of this tend
to be what he calls epistemic.
That is, they begin with an account
of what I would call "empty" content,
how someone takes the world to be.
And then, only then, I ask whether
and how that content is fulfilled.
And that's why epistemic accounts,
target objects as instantiating
properties and relations
and grouped in the settings,
into sets accordingly.
The ontological understanding
of the conceptual
that Brian is interested in,
starts with involvement in the world,
and then asks how aspects of it
are takings-of "something as something."
And the difference is
that the epistemic account presumes
that the something is objects,
and we take it as having
properties is and relations.
And Brian's account
is taking the world as articulated
into property objects and properties.
And hence, in doing so,
both objects & properties
are in the second something
on the far side of the "as."
And that's why Brian thinks
that epistemic accounts are
actually implicitly ontological
that is committed to taking the world
as already articulated into objects.
And that's what he's, of
course, putting into question.
The second theme,
which I'll be very brief about,
because we're,
is that, Brian thinks that the concept,
there's a kind of fine-grained richness
to the world that we encounter.
And that this is vindicated
in multiple ways.
First, by ordinary experience,
whose content and colors and the speed,
at which we drive around a corner,
and various other phenomena are,
you know, have a kind
of fine-grained richness
that outruns our conceptualizations.
He also thinks that's true
of scientific understanding
from the physics of fields,
which are not discreetly bounded,
to the practicalities of cartography,
which have to give boundaries to islands,
mountains, forest, coastlines,
and so forth,
where there's no exactly
determinant boundary to that.
But first and foremost,
I think, for Brian,
this is vindicated by the
history of the computational
& cognitive sciences.
First, by the failings
of good old-fashioned
artificial intelligence.
Second, by the,
(paper rustling)
you know, the practical challenges
of real-world computation
and especially now by the
comparative success compared
to GOFAI of machine-learning
& 2nd-wave AI.
I agree on all three of
these stories, all errors,
but I will say something more shortly
about how we characterize it.
The third theme,
some of the Aspects of
Conceptual Understanding
that figure in Brian's account.
First, that conceptual
understanding abstracts
from the diverse actual or
possible particular realizations
of the same conceptual content.
Second, that conceptual
understanding allows
the recombine ability of its concepts
in various predicative,
disjunctive or hypothetical judgments,
and in alethic, deontic,
& temporal modalities,
and various other reformulations.
A third point, which he said less about,
that Brian emphasizes
in a number of places
is what he calls,
would call, the causal non-effectiveness
of conceptual representation.
That my representing something
by itself is non-consequential.
And that it is also as such
indiscernible by others.
As he puts it at one point,
"You can't build an app
that will ping every time someone
in the world thinks about me," right?
It doesn't have that
kind of detectability.
Now it's important to realize
that this is one place
where Brian's ontological
conception really matters,
because if you take conceptualization
to be about a non-conceptual world,
then on an epistemic account,
that's gonna lead to a
kind of global skepticism
or a global disconnection, right?
That, you know,
we would be misrepresenting the world.
For Brian, that's not the case,
because we're already
in touch with the world.
And that to be genuinely
intentional and conceptual,
that conceptual understanding
then has to be concretized
back in action or application
what he calls "filling in"
such that the conceptual
content that's extracted from
then has to be filled
in in a concrete case,
to which we apply what we do.
And finally, the fourth
sort of initial theme
is The Normativity of
Intentional Directedness.
This is something that's
pretty widely familiar
and indeed is the source
of familiar concern
to naturalize intentionality
or conceptual understanding
by explaining how physical systems
that instantiate conceptual
can be answerable
to conceptual norms.
Traditional approaches
to this question start
with what Brian calls "statical norms"
truth, reference, and the like, right?
And as the target of either naturalization
or for those so inclined
as the target of non-natural
determination by reason.
And from that account
of the statical norms,
it then builds dynamical norms
of appropriate uses and inferences.
Brian's experiences in the
trenches of computer science,
cognitive science and AI,
suggests that that
strategy is broken back.
The dynamical norms of practice and use,
govern the statical norms
of truth and reference.
And this he points out,
has a very major consequence.
In that case,
something else must
determine the dynamical norm,
something other than merely
preserving the statical norms
of truth and reference.
Brian's much more
extensive response to this
in his papers than in the talk
is important, but unconventional,
in terms of the normativity of ontology.
For Brian, the dual sense
of matter and mattering,
of material ontology,
and material arguments or
material considerations
is no coincidence,
but, is in fact,
integral to what it is to be material.
He further specifies ontology
as the locust of a kind
of natural normativity.
This is now quoting from the paper
from which the talk is drawn.
Which abstractions a creature makes,
and thus, what objects
there are for that creature,
arises out of the constituently
norm-governed life
that that creature leads.
Objects, themselves,
exist in world's governed
by significance,
interpretation, and importance.
This is, I think,
a broadly biological
conception of normativity.
And it frames Brian's account
of truth as what is at issue
and at stake in conceptual activity.
Conceptual judgments are true
and the inferences we make are good.
If so taking them,
and fulfills the normative concerns
that governs a conceptual systems,
projects and practice.
Now, Brian notes and then rejects,
the widespread appeal to
evolutionary adaptation
to provide the relevant dynamical norms.
And he thinks that's the case
because he thinks that
it doesn't provide sufficient
normative articulation.
We need not just norms for
maintaining a way of life
and in terms of evolutionary survival,
but for sustaining a meaningful life,
a morally significant life.
And these more richly
differentiated normative concerns,
govern not only ethics,
politics and aesthetics,
but also ontology.
How the world we inhabit and answer to,
ought to be conceptualized
in living such lives?
So those four themes,
I think, are things that Brian
and I largely agree about.
They are also fairly unconventional,
even provocative in the
context of most thinking
on these subjects.
Even though,
you know, both our views are grounded in
and on the one hand,
in Brian's work on the cognitive
and computational sciences,
both of our work in
interdisciplinary science studies,
and my work in the philosophy
of scientific practice,
evolutionary biology and social theory.
Despite that agreement and placement
on one edge of contemporary debates,
its, I do have some questions
that point to consequential
differences in how we develop
and justify these provocative thesis.
I will have to be brief,
I've written about them
elsewhere at some length,
in both published and forthcoming work.
So the first question
concerns his initials,
as part of speculative characterization
of the Non-Conceptual World
as a Space of Features.
Whereas, underlying this,
there's a tension in Brian's project
that is trying to give a conceptual grasp
of a Non-Conceptual
World as Non-Conceptual.
And elsewhere, he recognizes that,
for example, in the artificial
intelligence book by talking,
by giving a demonstrative
indication of the world as that,
which is registered conceptually,
but can only be explicate
in further conceptual explications.
I have a couple of worries
though about the move
to feature space.
One is, that many of the
kinds of things Brian
is suggesting might be Features
of a Non-Conceptual World
are actually interactive aspects
of our engagement with the world.
I think of Kathleen Akins's
classic paper on thermoreceptors
as not getting the,
or as an objective feature,
but how temperature
matters to us or colors
as neither objective features of the world
nor subjective qualia.
And, perhaps, above all of
Karen Barad's conception
of objects is not an in,
as not intrinsic to the world,
but rather as intra-active.
And hence, a causal conception of things.
There's a deeper point as well,
and that is, that, you know,
Brian distinguishes
perceptual registration
of a Non-Conceptual World in conceptually,
and then doing conceptual work,
and then practically filling-in this.
Whereas, I think,
that perception and action
are always going on together.
All perception involves
practical activity,
all action is also
perceptually responsive,
and our engagement with that
and the world we are in is
densely causally entangled.
So that's gonna be my first question.
The relation between causal
entanglement or features
as a way of getting at
the richness of the
world that we agree on.
Second, I wanna ask a
question whether the world
that we inhabit actually
is in the non-conceptual?
And that's because the
fine-grained richness
of the worlds we live in
that we both agree about
is also crosscut with ostensions,
words, images, functional spaces,
equipment, and social roles.
These elements have a kind
of dual character, right?
Or that is they are also part
of the richly entangled
fabric of the world
and they are also
conceptually articulative.
I think, we need things
like Adam Lowe's paintings
and machine-learning algorithms
to abstract from our
pervasive concrete engagement
with our conceptually
articulative practices.
Phonemic articulation actually exemplifies
this duality, right?
We know that the phonemes people utter,
are continuous and
indistinguishable and yet,
but they also function discreetly
to mark out distinct phonemes.
And so part of what
I'm suggesting here is,
along with Brian,
that a conceptually
articulated world is not found,
but we nevertheless live in it
as already made by our practices.
The third issue, concerns
whether we should start instead
with "conceptuality in the wild,"
following on Ed Hutchinson's
"Navigation in the Wild"
and Brian's talk about
computation in the wild.
And I note, that despite
prioritizing dynamical norms,
Brian starts with a characterization
of conceptuality as statical.
We only get to inferences
as connecting determinate conceptual,
more or less determinate
conceptual contents.
I wanna talk about
conceptuality "in the wild"
that is in our conceptual practices,
and that starts with material inference
as integral to conceptual contents.
The content of a representation involves
its appropriate inferential connections
and with others.
So that is,
second, in that context,
our actual conceptual
engagement in the world,
definitely includes the conceptual role
of things like indexicals,
demonstratives, anaphora,
and their iconic and
expressive equivalence,
including the ways we negotiate
conceptual disagreements
via ostension, indirect
quotation, interpretation,
and so forth, right?
So I want to,
in this respect,
conceptual understanding
is not under our control.
The ways we articulate
the world conceptually
and assess its normative significance
is continually negotiated
with other agencies.
Human, to be sure,
but I would also argue non-human.
And like McDowell for the,
actually, it's going back
to the indexical's point.
I share with McDowell,
this emphasis on indexicals as conceptual,
but for very different reasons.
Finally, then I would add
that part of why I think GOFAI failed
is not merely that it didn't get at
the richness of the world,
but it also abstracts from the richness
and complexity of our conceptual life.
And so, the moral I would draw,
is the conceptuality has to
start with the dynamics of use
and not with the static
structures of conceptual systems.
My final question, reconsiders
normativity, evolution,
and the social ecological
world that we inhabit.
Well, I completely agree with Brian
in invoking the normative
complexity of human lives
and enhance the inadequacy of appeals
to simply to evolutionary adaptation.
Now, he understandably doesn't say much
about the normativity
involved here in detail.
He did more than enough for one talk.
But I note that he does seem to want
to begin with the ontology
of our conceptual
engagement with the world,
before situating it in a
broader normative space.
And I just think, that
in the end doesn't work.
Evolutionary biology,
in its traditional focus
on adaptation, won't do.
But evolutionary biology now
gives us much richer resources
for understanding dynamical norms.
In terms of organism,
environment, entanglement,
ecological developmental biology,
and niche construction, among others.
And so, looking to the
end of Brian's talk,
I think we need to ask how
and why our practices engage the world
at spacial temporal modal distances
for which its conceptual abstraction
from current situations is useful.
I think, both the need for
long distance understanding
and the possibility
and normative authority
of our conceptual practices
emerged first through
the evolution of a cooperative,
inter-cooperatively interdependent way
of life among early prominence.
And that in turn,
enabled our current practice
differentiated way of life.
The practices we each take up here and now
are closely interdependent
with other practices
and ways of life
that nevertheless mostly
take place at a distance.
And it's our need to sustain
that cooperative interdependence
among diverse practices
in practitioners is why
conceptual capacities evolved
and persist as long haul trucks & highways
for engaging with the world at a distance
and more abstractly.
That, however, has to be a
story for another occasion.
- Great.
Thank you so much, Joe, for that fantastic
and clearly laying out
the points of agreement
and the places where you have questions
that were raised by
Brian's talk yesterday.
And so, Brian, now, you have a few moments
to engage with him before
we have our questions
readied up for both of you.
- Okay, great.
Well, listen, thank you, Joe.
This is a fabulous,
in fact, clearer, I think,
especially up to the interlude,
clearer articulation
of what I wanted to say
than I myself said it.
I wanna make a note,
a kind of nod to John Hoagland,
the late John Hoagland,
the philosopher extraordinaire
that Joe and I both knew.
When Hoagland and I would
talk late in tonight often,
we developed a habit of
saying to each other,
"That's what I was just about to think."
And some of what you have done, Joe, here,
is I think,
you've earned this moniker,
I think, of respect and agreement of,
you know, yes, that's what
I was just about to think.
So, thank you for that
and for that clear articulation.
I wanna say a couple of things.
I'm not quite sure in what order,
but maybe this.
I think maybe one of the most
important things going on
in your response and my
characterization is that
I do lean a little bit
towards Evan's conception
of conceptuality.
And my sense is you are of a medallion
and I actually am more of
a medallion myself as well
in the sense that I kind of
agree more deeply with McDowell.
I think he's taking on the issue
of being engaged with the world cut deep.
So, you, I think,
this is fair to say,
especially, for example,
in your third point
of dealing with
conceptuality in the world,
sorry, in the wild.
Of course, in the world too,
but in the wild.
I think the kind of conceptuality
that you're getting at
is what would be going on in the wild,
might include things that I wouldn't,
in my talk, at least,
have called conceptual.
Now, there is-
- My question's absolutely right.
- There is an issue as to
how we should use this word
because one possible question
I could have got yesterday
and I was wondering if I get it
and nobody actually asked
it is the following,
"Look, Brian,
your sense of..."
I remember I said yesterday
that the conception of the
ridge didn't turn the ridge into
a sort of conceptual object.
It was still the rich object that it was.
Somebody might have asked me,
"Look, is there any conceptual ontology
or is that just a sort
of theoretical fantasy
that people have used as a
way of explaining actually
the content of language
and so on and so forth."
And I actually think it's a mistake.
There actually isn't any that
human intentionality never
is fully conceptual,
in the sense, in Brian's,
sorry, sense of conceptuality.
Certainly, I think,
and I think this matters
to the discussion.
I do not think that all of our thought
or our use of language
is in fact conceptual.
Remember I talked about the poets,
I talked about that
quote from Henry James,
and what it was that his words did
to our understanding of afternoon tea.
Now, in a way, if you
went to McDowell route
and your sort of conceptuality
in the wild route,
you might think that,
"Look, that quote from James
is an indication of how powerful
conceptual articulation is,
such that it's not
anything like as restricted
as Evan's conception."
And,
and I would probably answer yes.
Isn't it amazing how powerful
human understanding is?
And I'm not sure I wanna say
that that's human
conceptual understanding.
So I think,
the first glass of whiskey
we need to drink is on how...
Okay, you and I both agree
that what conceptual means
is not God-given in advance,
it has to do with the
practice for invasion
and all this kind of stuff
and so on and so forth, right?
The way we recite the canon.
What it would be most useful
and most penetratingly insightful
for us to do with this word conceptual
and what it is that it should refer to,
I think is not yet known, at least.
I mean, I think that would be
a real issue of substantive,
well, it might look like a
mere issue of semantical debate
is the word semantics is
used in Barnes & Noble.
I think that's a real issue,
'cause where are the joints or boundaries
and so on and so forth
in our understandings?
I said that we live in this middle region
and move back and forth and stuff,
and in my sense of what
it used to pick up a cup,
"Look, can you hand me that cup?"
And,
what happens,
I mean,
what's his name?
Rick Grush is very good on this.
I think the,
how the forms of representation
that actually guide your
hand take over from anything
that is conceptually available to you
and actually guide your hand
so that it can pick up
that cup successfully.
You know, how much of
that you wanna include
in your sense of conceptuality
and so on and so forth?
Hard to know.
So, we made here for a little bit
on where we think it's useful
to bring down the word conceptual,
that's one thing.
I do wanna make a comment though on,
this applies to evolution
and the richer suite of
resources it provides us,
but it's more easily explicable
I think with respect to Karen or Rod
and her intra-causal interactions
and so on and so forth.
There is a causalism,
that I think,
you know, Karen is a
social construction person.
She's not a reductionist on
any normal notion of reduction
except I think she has
drunk the causalist Kool-Aid
that underwrites naturalism.
And she thinks you can actually give
an account through causal interactions
and actually get everything that way.
And I,
my sense is, that what's
happened to us intellectually
in our evolution, if you like,
is...
That forms of causal interaction
and maybe evolutionary arguments
and cooperation and so on and so forth,
were initially what led us
to develop maybe language
and so on and so forth.
But that we've outstripped those resources
and my sense of wonder at that,
which is causally inaccessible.
I mean, you know,
the notion of the light
cone, for example, with,
and I can imagine things
outside the light cone
even though no one has ever,
no one I've ever interacted with
has interacted with stuff
outside the light cone
and so on and so forth.
I mean, just by definition,
that's what a light cone is.
But the nice thing of a
light cone is not madness,
it's actually very highly accepted.
And I think the fact that we understand it
and that we wonder,
we wonder at it.
We wonder at the universe,
and so on and so forth.
Well, the second whiskey is
even with its new fund resources,
is modern evolutionary
theory still has it drunk
the causalist Kool-Aid,
or do we actually need
something more than that
in order to be oriented
towards to have deference to,
wonder about and so on and so forth?
That which is beyond,
beyond any causal interaction.
And I have a,
I have a ton of respect for that,
which is not within our reach.
I mean, Yates,
was it Yates?
"A man's reach should
exceed his grasp," right?
And, apologize for the sexism,
but,
but the reach of our
understanding outstrips
are causal grasp even no matter how social
and historical and so and so forth.
He takes with social grasp
and so on and so forth.
So that's the causalism,
the causal Kool-Aid,
that I think permeates
what I think you're saying
and how it differs from what I think.
How much the causal Kool-Aid
is in fact correlated with
any of other agreements
or disagreements?
That's a question I think
that would take thought,
but that would be,
that would be,
that would be worth exploring.
And then the thing about the features
and the fact that I introduced this stuff,
you know, conceptually in a certain sense.
I tell stories, right?
About, "Look, isn't it like this
when in fact you're
paddling down the river
and whatever and so on and so forth."
Now you can say, "Look,
that's a conceptual account
because you've used words."
That would be a conceptual account,
only if the use of words was
intrinsically conceptual,
which I think my aversion to
poets and so and so forth,
suggests that I don't thin, so.
So that potential critique,
I think is hinges on the
first thing I was saying about
the use of the word conceptual
and so on and so forth.
But I also think that
this phrase, "that which,"
that which I,
beat my paddle into,
that which I drink down and say,
"This is a fabulous 24
old years Smoky Scotch
or something,"
that which I drink isn't
rendered conceptual
by the fact that I have referred to it
by these words, "That which I drink,"
even if I and drink are
formulated as words.
Because I think,
and this was in a way my
point about the reference of,
the reference of terms towards things
that they conceptually structure.
I don't think the reference of words
is restricted to a
conception of those, right?
The actual reference,
the reference in the world,
not the meaning.
I don't think that which I
refer to is rendered conceptual
in virtual fact that I have referred
to it using even concepts,
let alone word.
And so that I think is,
I feel as if there's a kind of
profound deference,
to how,
you know, I'm almost tempted
to run into what language might be,
to language that people might
think of as almost religious.
Deference to that which
transcends my understanding,
I think, permeates what I'm trying to say.
And I think it's important.
I don't wanna give that up lightly.
I think there is humility
and a deference and a recognition
of that which is beyond,
that which lies beyond,
which people have struggled to hear,
voice to in human history.
In many traditions,
mystical and not otherwise,
and so on and so forth.
And I don't think it's empty,
I don't think the fact that
it's being used words is empty.
So that fundamental deference,
the fundamental
non-commitment to causalism
and that Kool-Aid,
and maybe our difference in
the use of the word conceptual
and God knows many other things, so.
(Joseph chuckles)
But thank you for your wonderful comments.
- Yeah.
Couple of things that I think
are really interesting here
because the points on which
you're calling attention to,
the deferences, I think have relate,
are all interrelated.
Okay?
So we'll start with the causal point.
Think that one of the things
we've learned from thinking
in the philosophy of science
about causality is that in,
is that causal,
you know, the way you're
talking about causality
has the same problem
that you think traditional way
of talking about the world is,
that is, that call entanglement
is as rich and dense and multi,
we wanna say multifactorial,
but of course-
- Right.
- It's prior to the distinction.
- Right, articulation, yeah.
- Right.
And that we variously
model and abstract causes,
discrete causes and conceptualize them
from that causal entanglement.
So it's first of all
emphasizing that we are in,
you know, that we are part of
and entangled in that
larger conceptual unity.
The unity, not in the
sense of non heterogeneity.
On the contrary, causal relations are in,
you know, enormously diverse, right?
But we have to do work
to abstract and structure them.
- No.
- But, you're.
- Yeah.
- So just to quickly interrupt.
I mean, aren't causal relations,
for example, in physics,
they're always mediated by
what we call as laws, right?
I mean, there are,
these relations are informed
by conservation laws
or what have you, right?
- Well, I have a whole long account
of how to think about laws
and modal in variance,
which is absolutely crucial
to scientific understanding
and its connection to the normativity
of scientific practice.
And so this is of long,
long chapter of articulating the world.
It is comprises that laws
are ways of conceptualizing
and projecting concepts
in ways that are
accountable to the practices
and concerns of the discipline.
So that would actually fit
law-governed conceptualization
into something like Brian's.
- No, but look, this is an agreement
I don't think I want us hold.
(Joseph laughs)
'Cause I think, first of all,
I think, with Priya,
I mean, I think of,
okay, so this is notion of effectiveness
in computer science,
effective computation.
- Yeah.
- And what that is is something I,
I'm actually writing about at the moment.
And,
you know, an effective property,
maybe a causal property,
I actually think the word
effective in computer science
is a better word than causal
because there's so much
complication with repectocausal.
But to go to Priya,
I mean, there is a kind of look,
falls off as one over R-squared,
you know, is local in time
and space and something.
There is something about the
aboriginal notion of causation
in physics and stuff
that you can't actually,
you know, violate,
and do consequent work.
That is absolutely fundamental,
computer science would actually be empty
if that were not a restriction.
And the question is,
can you understand deference
to that which is absent?
Within an account, which actually obeys
all the irregularities of which in fact,
all under the one over
R-squared falling off as,
you know, following up with
one over R-squared kinds
of constraints of effectiveness.
And I think the answer is no.
And, you know, the fact that
the scientific revolution
can be characterized as,
in fact, this fabulous hypothesis
on who knows Picard's art, if you like.
Bacon and stuff.
That, in fact, the world can be explained
in virtue its causal nature
and its causal laws and
stuff has to have substance.
If you generalize the notion of causation
to be everything that we can,
that scientists can actually
come up with accounts
of regularities and stuff,
then causal doesn't mean anything anymore.
Scientific revolution is
not a particular insight.
And the thing is,
I think computer science shows us
that it's an extremely important insight
that is in fact had differentiates
what's computable or not.
And if you generalize
notion of effectiveness,
I can solve a halting problem
for 25 cents or even a nickel.
So,
so I wanna say that
reference is not causal,
but hanging onto a notion of causal
such that reference isn't it,
is actually fundamental to
doing justice to science.
And so I think you generalize
the notion of causation
at the peril of understanding
what science is and what constraints it.
- The other point I
was gonna make is that,
in fact, the kinds of
notions of effectiveness
and the limits of effectiveness
that you're talking about are also very,
very important for my view
as are the role of modal
and variance in the sciences
and the different kinds of modal
and variance in different fields.
The ways in which there
are law-governed relations
in the life sciences, for example,
that hold even under
or counter normal logical hypotheses
in terms of laws, right?
I mean, classic example,
that the fisher explanation for
or sex ratios at birth,
would hold even if the physics of sex
and chemistry affect sex
determination were different.
So we can handle that.
I agree with you on the point about,
let's say, understanding the,
you know, what's beyond
the light cone, right?
We are able to do that with,
indeed, we're able to talk about
and understand all sorts of
things at distances and reserve
that we have no direct
causal contact with, okay?
I mean, there's no problem with that.
The point I'm making
is that you can only do that
because you are already participating
in a broad wide variety
of causal practices
is that enable those
that account to have
that conceptual content.
- But, Joe, I might agree with you,
but only in the following sense,
and this is something I
said to Dan Dennett once.
- Yeah.
- Which is, "Look, you
keep going back to biology
and you keep going back to
the evolutionary account
of our emergence."
And I said, "Yeah, that's
the train we got here on."
I am not arguing that that's
the train we got here on,
but I don't think the
train of how we got here
is an actual explanation of where we are.
You know, so the fact that
that's how it emerged,
which is of course the kind
of explanation of something
that someone who believed
in causes would tend
to think was explanatory,
'cause you're explaining something
by your causal emergence.
- Well, no.
Brian, here's the-
- Only the train.
- Here's the point.
- Right,
but the trajectory matters, right?
- I mean, the trajectory matters
of how you got here, right?
- It does, indeed.
And, see, part of the point here
is that I'm in agreement with you
that there's more to the world we inhabit
than we can articulate conceptual, okay?
But I'm thinking about that
in a slightly different way than you are
because I do think
that the ability to engage with,
for example, the fine-grained
richness of the world
and the multiplicity of
in causal entanglement
can be indicated conceptually.
Now here's the example
that seems to me striking,
it's,
the more, which we can be,
we can also indicatively point towards,
or there's more to the
world than we understand.
More-
- Right.
- You know, more in the heavens than earth
than you've up in your
philosophy Horatio, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- But that's not the
fine-grained richness,
which admittedly,
you know, we can't reproduce in words
and we don't wanna try,
even the poets are not reproducing it
or representing it in its detail,
but evoking it.
The contrast is to those
aspects of the world
that are utterly beyond our ken.
And I think that's one of the things
that the history of the
sciences brings out for us.
That is, what it is to bring
whole domains of the world
that we can now talk about,
engage with, in part of course,
by constructing experimental systems,
enable us to get it to
show up in particular ways
that previously were
completely ineffable, right?
We talk about the growth of
knowledge of the sciences,
but actually what's been most striking
is the growth of what we can talk about,
what we can actually engage with,
and make sense of,
bring into the conceptual domain.
And there-
- I mean, it's a,
it's sort of the confluence
of ideas and instruments,
not just ideas.
Because it's the instruments
that enable new conversations about ideas
and generates.
- And the practices, in which
we employ those instruments
and the situations in which we're in.
I mean, here's a lovely recent example.
Oh, the ways, in which it's
genetic sequencing has uncovered
a massive proliferation
of the microbial world
that couldn't be,
you know, we had no clue this was there
because we had no way to culture it.
And which is the only way to make,
to get access to by,
that's the more of the world.
And, you know,
and it's actually our
conceptual capacities
which enable us even to
articulate that, right?
So we're in agreement to a great deal.
And my worry is that,
we actually need to recognize
in scientific understanding
the entanglement of the
modal and the normative
that causality is not one kind of relation
but a rich panoply of entanglements,
which we then model, articulate,
and engage with in part
of course by instruments
and creating phenomena in
laboratory that bring things out.
And also, by building
inferential relations,
including the poetic
which do an important sort of word.
So, I,
you know, you're worried
that I'm making the poets too conceptual.
I think, Priya, was initially worried
that I'm making the scientific
understanding too poetic.
- Poetic, yes.
- Right?
And what I wanna argue is that
the making of it is poetic,
is actually
the causal niche
construction, reconstruction,
of the worlds we can encounter.
And that-
- And-
- You know, and that
involves not just new words,
but new practices, new engagements.
It depends on the stuff that we are-
- And even new logics, if need be.
- Oh, well, yeah, sure.
No.
Oh, and the final point,
you know, 'cause you
were raising as a worry,
a possible worry about your talk.
Someone might say,
"Well, the kinds of abstract
conceptual structures
that say, Evans is talking about,
don't really refer to anything."
That's not you.
My view is that they have
an important expressive role
in enabling us to talk about
the rich entangled conceptual
relations in the wild.
But they are dependent,
just as you are arguing
that our ability to talk
and conceptualize and represent at all,
depends on our involvement in the world,
which we completely agree about, right?
I think, that our ability
to articulate these formal
relations are expressions of
and dependent upon the much richer set
of material inferential relations,
including the ways, in
which we differ about them.
So you and I can talk
about what is conceptual,
even though we have different
agreements about exactly
what the conceptual is.
Because,
in the end, we're talking about
many of the same practices
about scientific understanding,
about causal relations.
And the question is no to our that.
- Yeah.
- But I think, I don't
disagree with you about
the vast expansive role
of imagination of instruments
and practices in science
and so on and so forth,
how it's opened up this,
all this kinda stuff.
I mean, the flourishing,
the expansiveness,
you know, the richness, the entanglement,
and so on and so forth,
all of the things that you say,
which I think, Priya's nodding by.
(Joseph laughs)
Is not the best poker player.
- Unfortunately, I'm not
playing poker. (laughs)
- I don't play, and we're
not playing poker, right.
- That's good, I would've lost already.
I agree with all of that.
The question is, is that germane?
Like, how comprehensive is that,
that the realms that are being expanded
by these discussions.
You know, this is where you're a Baradi
and I think the...
(Joseph chuckles)
You know, I think this
causal Kool-Aid goes deeper
than this issue of conceptual
and non-conceptual.
I think,
you really drank this Kool-aid.
You have a sense that you can sort of get-
- Before I met Karen.
- I mean,
we are going have to
invite Professor Barad
to comment here as you finish.
- Yes, she's here.
- Yeah. (chuckles)
- Yeah, no, I've wanted to,
I actually have notes on a,
you know, 'cause her title,
"Meeting the Universe Halfway"
is such a great title.
But, causal interactionism,
I think, just screams at me
with the limits of what it is
that her metaphysical conception, right?
And I wanna say, "Look, you
wanna not be a reductionist
and you've successfully
achieved not exemplifying
so many of the properties
that reduction exist,
except the fundamental ones,"
which is to actually think
that you could explain things
in terms of causal practices
and causal irregularities
and all of this kind of stuff.
And I don't think
that what Yates was talking about or,
you know, it's funny you say that,
you know, we understand
that there's nowhere that,
there's more to the
world than is dreamt of
in your philosophy or something.
You know, I think we agree with that.
I actually had a quote in
my book about there's less
in the world than is dreamt
of in your philosophy,
which I stole from,
I stole from,
what's his name?
The guy who wrote worlds
ways a world like she...
Anyway,
my dad was an Islamist,
is if I can bring up a different topic.
And he actually felt that
the right way to understand
the the muezzin's call
on Friday night was,
I know that,
I know that there's more to all,
it may be Allah,
to Allah than I know
there to be or something.
And the Allah stuff doesn't really matter,
I think, in these foundations
of recruiting practice.
It's like, I know that
there is more than I know
that there is kind of.
- [Priya] Right.
- And the contradictory
nature of that I think is,
is sort of crucial.
And I guess I feel like-
- I mean, why do you say
that it's contradictory?
I mean, it's just having
awareness of the limits
of knowledge, right?
I mean...
- Well-
- Limits of your conceptual
knowledge or your ability.
- Well, no, but no, it's tricky.
'Cause if you said there's
more than the world
than I understand, that would be easy.
To say that there's more than I know,
I know that there's more
than I know there to be is,
you know, that's kind of,
I mean, that's a challenge, right?
- Yeah, there's another
layer wrapped up there.
- There's another layer there.
I guess, my sense of what has mattered
to me about people I've known,
just to be very personal about this,
is actually,
a shared deference
to that which is beyond
rich patterns of causal
intra-action and engagement
and so on and so forth.
I just,
I find the restriction to,
I mean, you're absolutely right,
extremely rich and extremely
being better understood
all the time and so on and so forth.
Patterns of causal interaction,
I think, and casual engagement,
and all of this kind of stuff.
I mean, the stuff that
the scientific revolution
actually opened our eyes too.
I think,
it just feels to me like a projection
onto the wall of the cave
and that no matter how
rich the shadows are,
that there was something
to the scientific revolution's claim
that we can explain the
universe in these terms,
even if they had no
idea about the resources
of revolutionary biology now
and so on and so forth,
the niche construction and God knows what.
I think it's still a shadow of that
to which we defer.
- Right, mm-hmm.
- As I think it is part of what that,
to which we refer.
- Well, of course, I agree with that.
- And it only gets its sense as an ongoing
and open-ended articulation
of that, right?
Because, I mean, the two things-
- But, right, no, we
would agree with that,
but the question is,
is that open-ended exploration
open to any understanding we get of it,
or is it closed methodologically
because of a commitment
to causal explanation?
And I think if it's the former,
then there's nothing to say.
- I wouldn't say it's closed,
but it's restricted, right?
If you have a commitment to causal.
- Yeah.
- Well, if you haven't
restricted the causal,
then I think you're not
gonna explain things
that in fact, the fundamental
constituent regularities
of which are not causal.
And I think reference is one thing,
the fundamental,
the fundamental regularities
of which are not causal.
That's I think the importance
of that impossible-
- And, see, here's,
I think this is where,
there's actually more
agreement than you think.
Because reference,
in the sense in which you mean it, okay?
So the way in which
you can utter sentences
that refer to things that we
are causally disconnected with,
I have no problem with, okay?
We do that,
that's one of the,
next question, how do we do that, right?
And, you know, this is where
I think the dynamical norms
of conceptual articulation
and the ways in which
the concepts themselves
get their content from how
we engage with the world,
how we engage with one another.
- But-
- The concepts relate
to one another inferentially,
which allows you to express new things.
Maybe you have to write a novel
in order to develop the concepts to point
to, you know, without,
of often what novelists are doing, right?
But they're thereby allowing
us to refer to things
that we previously couldn't refer to.
- Well, I think there's truth to that,
but the problem is,
to argue that they do that in virtue,
rich causal engagements
and stuff is circular.
Because, in fact, if the
reference of the novel
is something that rich patterns
of causal engagement can't explain,
then in fact, what it is
that they're referring to
can't be explained that way.
The thing is,
my sense, I mean, this is
the McDowell part of you
I think that I think is actually
a little bit incompatible
with the Barad part of you.
One of the senses I have of McDowell
is that part of what it is
to be conceptual for him
is that it is in fact part
of a conception of the world, right?
And McDowell is not anyone
who's lost any sleep
over not being compatible
with any scientific results.
(Joseph laughs)
(Brian chuckles)
That's one of the virtues of being
a Pittsburgh philosophy department.
But the thing is, the
conception of the world,
holding things accountable
to being part of the world, right?
Which is something
McDowell feels, I think,
and something Hoagland
actually believed in deeply.
I think that conception
of being a whole world,
that which is one that beyond,
which there isn't anything
and so on and so forth.
I don't think that can be explained
in terms of rich patterns of causal.
- Okay, so I think at this point
we should probably
invite if Professor Barad
is interested in commenting.
- Absolutely, and also next year
you have to invite us all to bring
the novels we're gonna write.
- (laughs) Well, not me. (laughs)
- Sorry, Priya, I didn't
mean to interrupted you.
- No, not at all.
I have invited Professor Barad to...
- [Karen] Well, hi,
thanks for inviting me.
- Hi.
- Oh, hi, Karen.
- Lovely to see you.
- [Karen] Thanks to you both,
for this amazing exchange.
I'm just gonna be super brief by saying
that I don't know how
much Joe is a Baradian,
but I'm certainly a Rousean.
(Priya laughs)
And I think that he's,
I think that Joe has done a marvelous job,
addressing Brian's objections about this.
And so I'm just gonna leave it at that.
Thanks.
- Thank you so much, Karen.
It was such-
- Thank you, Karen.
I had no idea you were here, so.
(Joseph laughs)
- Otherwise,
you wouldn't have talked about
me drinking Kool-Aid, I bet.
(Priya laughs)
(Joseph laughs)
- I would not have.
- No, we'll bring you
in on the whiskey, K.
(Karen laughs)
(Brian chuckles)
That will be much more fun.
- [Karen] I look forward to that, yeah.
(Joseph laughs)
(Brian chuckles)
- That'll be great.
The first round's on me.
- Karen, thank you so much.
- [Karen] Yeah.
- Okay.
I mean, I guess I have one quick question,
but I think I'll wait
and I'll turn it over to
people in the audience today.
And I think June Lao has a question,
"It seems that under Brian's
conception of both conceptual
and non-conceptual forms of normativity,
there is no reduction to causation,
evolution, or practice.
Does the debate here may
not be about conceptual
versus non-conceptual per se,
but about the constitution of normativity?
By Brian's conception,
the non-conceptual world
plays an irreducible role
in the constitution of normativity,
conceptual or non-conceptual,
and that aspect is not
captured by causal evolutionary
and practical accounts.
Is that correct?"
Yeah, I mean, I think
it's my understanding too,
but I could have missed something.
- But I think, June's comment
is actually interesting.
The last sentence I think is,
it's too easy to answer it
in the way in which it's framed.
So I wanna sort of raise the anti,
and then also agree with
the raised anti-version.
Is it captured by causal evolutionary
and practical accounts?
I think that's correct,
it is not.
But I would say something stronger,
which is that the
constitution of normativity
in the human case,
and I don't know about
other biological animals.
I think this might be a place
we actually have sort of transcended
our biological heritage.
The constitution of normativity,
conceptuality and
non-conceptuality in the human case
is not captured by causal evolutionary
or practical phenomena.
So in other words, it's
not just the accounts,
it's what those accounts are accounts of
I think, that is not enough.
So yes, I agree with
you and raise you one.
(Joseph chuckles)
- Great.
Thank you so much, June,
for that great question.
So as we wait for more people
to chime in with their questions,
so I wanted a clarification, right?
So, and the clarification
is about the negotiation
of conceptual disagreements, right?
- Yeah.
- So, is it that the arbitration
or negotiation between
different conceptual accounts
of reality is not actually
challenging per se
at the end of the day
because you share a
lexicon and a language,
or are there incommensurable,
not that I wanna sort of evoke June here,
but, you know.
- Neither one,
and I think this is an
important question, I think.
Because what I tend to do,
I think, would tend to do with
the consensual disagreement
is I would say, "Look,
come over from here."
Let's just sit down
or maybe we're gonna go
walk around the field
and, you know, and...
Now, why?
Because having dinner and
walking around the field
and having libations in
common and so on and so forth,
is a form of engagement
that is not entirely within
the conceptual realm.
And I don't think
that sharing of vocabulary,
I mean, we do share vocabulary
in some sense, right?
I know this word conceptual, for example.
And,
you know, it's different across languages.
I mean, it's interesting
that in French, I believe,
(speaks French) is the French
translation of two words
in English, "Conscience
and consciousness."
And I have asked people
who are native French speakers,
whether they actually have,
French makes only one notion such that it,
we, English, have pulled
it apart or what's going
and so on and so forth.
And I've had different answers.
Some French people that are
trained in analytic philosophy
and stuff, think, "Look,
it's just a word that's
used for both things
and no French person is confused."
And I've had other French people say,
"No, that's absolutely right"
and it's interesting and it
matters to French society
and so on and so forth.
So the point is sharing words is tricky.
But I don't even think
if Joe and I, who are pretty
damn close in this pantheon,
if we use a word,
we may use the same word,
but that doesn't mean
we mean the same thing
or are getting it the same thing.
And I remember saying this to John Barrois
and John Perry once,
and I said, "Look, I
don't think that when,
you know, we use,
the words mean different things
in different contexts of use and stuff.
And they said, "Yeah,
no, we agree with that,"
but by and large, within
a sort of American society
in late 20th century, whatever,
you know, they mean the same thing.
And I said, "No, that's not right at all.
I think, in fact, even
when I use the word,
I'm not sure it means the same thing
at the beginning of a sentence
and at the end of a sentence."
And they said, "Yeah, we know."
So-
(Joseph laughs)
I think,
it's not an absolute disagreement.
It's not that we,
if we use the same word,
that therefore we mean the same thing.
I don't think it means
it's incommensurable.
I don't think it means we
can't learn from other people.
You know, when I said to John Hoagland,
"Look, that's what I was
just about to think."
My mind can be stretched
and it's stretched by Joe
and he's adjusting.
You know, it's like bending a
note on a guitar or something.
You know, it can bend
what the word means for me
and so on and so forth.
I think the nature of our
concepts is much more plastic
and fluid and contextual and
all of this kind of stuff,
then with all respect to question
or at least connotes with that question.
- And I would wanna add there
that that process of ongoing
negotiation of our concepts
and words with one another
and with what we're talking about
and the sense that
this is accountable to the world.
- Right.
- Is really,
really crucial to all of this.
So when you talk about,
you know, what our words mean
and what we're talking about, right?
I wanna draw a slight
differentiation there, right?
Because I come into our conversation with,
let's say, a word like, conceptual,
or a word like, causal,
with actually entangled set
of inferential relations,
which differ from yours.
Okay, there's some overlap,
but there's a lot of differentiation
and, you know, and we,
but, of course, we're
committed to the idea that,
as, I think, characteristic of
what it is to be conceptual,
that these can be
adjudicated and worked out.
Not that we will,
but that they can.
And this is an,
this involves reworking
and engaging the, you know...
- Yeah.
- Right, but where does-
- And something like the
very point you're making
that objects and properties
are on the far side
of the something as something, right?
That we're having to
renegotiate what we think,
you know, objects become
the point of contact
and ostensive if pointing out.
I'm talking about that,
and this-
- Right.
But, I mean, in all of these then-
- Characterize that differently than I do.
- Right.
- That provides a point,
which is then,
you know, exactly what we
mean by what we should mean,
lies ahead of us.
So in that sense,
on my account, normativity
and temporality,
normativity and conceptual,
they are temporal phenomenon.
- Nice, no, but in all of this-
- Out of past practice looking ahead.
- What is stability?
- Go, Priya.
- Does stability of
meaning a casualty then?
I mean, is there
stability of meaning or...
- I think, think about
being in the North Atlantic
in a small boat.
If you're standing in a small boat
in a North Atlantic storm,
stability doesn't come from being rigid.
If you stand rigidly,
you're gonna be tossed into the drink.
(Joseph chuckles)
Stability arises from being
extremely capable of dancing.
And so I think there are stabilities
that require exquisitely
fine orchestrated movements
and so on.
- Yeah.
- But the thing I wanna say
to Joe here is this,
think about axiomatizations
of arithmetic and stuff.
How do you negotiate
different logical systems
and so on and so forth, right?
And figure out whether in fact,
you know, Peano arithmetic is
consistent or whether in fact,
you know, getting rid of,
what's his name, Peter Axel,
who has this axiom,
that in fact allows
self membership in sets
but the whole thing's consistent is on.
There are norms on
axiomatizations arithmetic.
Now all the axiomatizations
are gonna be effective, right?
Because in fact, if you don't let,
you don't require syntactic
axiomatization to be effective,
the whole thing drops into vacuity.
- Yeah.
- So they'll negotiate.
And then there are theorems
about these things.
But they're meant to be
axiomatizations of arithmetic
and of mathematics and stuff.
And those things are not themselves
effective subject matter.
- Yeah.
- And I don't think the,
the development of
axiomatizations of mathematics,
of course, it has an
effective causal history.
It has to, because in fact,
we're all physicalist.
(Joseph laughs)
But the fact that it has
an effective causal history
doesn't mean that it's explained by
the syntactic manipulations, right?
I mean, that's one thing Barrois said
that was the fundamental
result of 20th century logic,
was that you couldn't
reduce semantics to syntax.
- And we're in agreement here.
- Well, but then the question is,
can semantics be given an account in a,
you know,
well, Karen, I have such respect for you
that now that you're in the audience,
I'm very reluctant to speak.
(Joseph laughs)
Can you give an account of,
can you give an account that explains
the wrestlings in the
foundations of mathematics
with axiomatizations of arithmetic
in the terms of these complex
patterns of entanglement
and so on and so forth.
And my intuition's ultimately, no.
You've got to actually refer
to the mathematical entities
that people are trying to give,
you know, explain through a glass darkly.
I don't, then up that (indistinct).
- But, Brian.
Oh, Karen, gonna come
in on that or that was,
was that you, Priya?
- No, no, it was just me.
I was gonna say that we have
a couple of questions as well
that are-
- Oh, okay.
- So there's one that Ty has.
Ty, did you wanna go ahead for a second?
- Yeah, absolutely.
Thank you for this exchange.
In the article, Brian,
that you submitted for your talk page,
the third day.
So you write about the registration effect
of Lowe's painting, right?
Versus the abstractness,
the abstraction of
presentation of Magritte
in the Treachery of Images,
otherwise known as "Ceci
n'est pas une pipe"
So from my limited understanding,
from what I gleaned from the article,
our civilization was not until
fairly recently it seems,
producing paintings like Lowe's.
Is that because we had
not yet evolved enough
to extend what you call
that middle distance?
And, if so, what kind of
painting might we evolve
into the more we learn to
extend said middle distance?
- Well-
- I told you,
you have an historian of art
and historian of modern
contemporary art here, so.
- Yeah, no, I know.
So now, I'm on treading.
- Where we go after data,
in other words? (chuckles)
- A mad dog or an Englishman, right?
I'm gonna tread where only fools would go.
- Go ahead.
- Think about, my name is Red.
You know, prime comics book
about Islamic miniatures
and so on and so forth, right?
And the paintings talk in that.
And there's a painting that says,
"Look,"
you know, in the sort of
conversion to modernism and stuff.
I wasn't meant to represent
what a tree looks like,
I was meant to represent
the soul of a tree or something like that.
And,
I'm not sure.
I mean, think about prehistoric images
of pregnancy goddesses
and so on and so forth.
I'm not sure that they were,
they were not
"Ceci n'est pas une pipe"
type representations.
So I don't know if it's
true that it's only recently
that we have paintings like,
Adam's painting of that door.
I would defer, but we've
gotta invite Adam. (chuckles)
I'm not sure, I'm not sure,
I guess is what I'm saying.
- Well, you know, I'm also going to step
into where I shouldn't be treading.
But I mean, you know,
Adam's paintings have,
do have a history.
Think back to impressionism
and the effort to capture
the look of things, right?
And part of my point
is that the ways in which we depict things
and how we understand depiction
and articulation in
painting is also conceptual.
Oh, oh, I don't,
I have no idea whether
Gary Tomlinson is here
in the audience at Yale.
But, Gary's work on music
and it's relation to language is also,
I think, a really lovely example here
to actually see the kinds of
expressive capacities of music
and how it articulates
aspects of the world.
I'm not tripping this to Gary, by the way,
but, you know, that that is,
comes together with the kinds of practices
that allow us to take things
as being about something else, right?
That was the dramatic
innovation of practices,
in which we are dependent upon one another
in ways that allow us
to take what one another
is doing as not, you know,
so clear as to what to do now,
but it's about something else.
And that's-
- So, Joe,
do you think everything.
- Instructions.
- Do you think everything-
- You know, I mean,
what is Adam's painting about and of?
What is-
- Yeah.
- Now, of course they are.
The other forms of pictorial articulation
and depiction are working
in different ways.
And you have to actually
get into how they're working
and what they're doing,
and how they're,
you know, how they're seeing things as,
and that is both the things
and they ask, right?
- But do you think,
I mean, I guess I wanna say is,
I mean, I think there're two
points of disagreement here,
which are conspiring together
and that's kind of tricky.
- More than two, I think, actually.
- Okay.
Yeah, maybe nine of them are rolled up.
- But they're all connected together.
It's one agreement that
has multiple elements.
- But I guess what I wanna ask is,
look, Yates and Henry James,
and the Bhagavad Gita and stuff,
they all use words.
- Uh-hmm.
- Does that mean that they're
all conceptual for you?
- It's not that they are words
that makes them conceptual,
it's in part,
they're belonging to conceptual
and discursive practices
that makes them words.
Right? (chuckles)
And, that
so we speak a language,
and that gives us extraordinary
expressive resources.
You know, new ways of combining them
and speaking those words
and engaging them in various settings
that of course go way beyond.
You know, they are
recommendable in rich ways
that are not simply
mathematically functional, right?
- Yeah. I mean, that's what I was trying
to talk about yesterday
with Nunberg's characterization
of the rise of information
that, yes, languages.
- Yeah, and I agree with you on that.
I mean, you know,
this is not concatenations of information.
- Right, it's not.
- Really.
And I think the whole of conceptual life
cannot be adequately treated that way.
- Well, okay, so suppose we agree on that,
then if I ask you what you think
about this McDowell debate,
McDowell Evan's debate about
can there be conceptual,
non-conceptual content?
Is it unfair to say the following?
Now, somebody asks me,
"Does Joe Rouse believe
there can be non-conceptual content?"
And I say to him, this
person's or whatever,
"No, Joe, does not think
there can be non-conceptual content,
because the very idea of
conceptual content is for him,
sufficiently comprehensive with respect
to our discursive practices
that anything we say is gonna
be located in this historical
and grounded and contextualized
practice such that,
and conceptual content for Joe
is to be something meaningfully
conveyed in that practice.
And so therefore, by definition,
there can be no non-conceptual content."
How much injustice does that do to you?
- Well, I have problems with all of that.
- (laughs) Okay, good.
- The conceptual and the non-conceptual
with the notion of content, right?
That is, that I think
that we can only
do anything conceptual
as part of a life engaged
in the world interactively
in an ongoing way.
And that having these practices,
which are on the one hand,
very, very closely interconnected.
So when you think about painting practices
and the ways in which they comment
on previous painting practices,
but also are accountable to these larger,
more long distance engagements, right?
I mean, impressionism
arises in the 19th century
for to do with.
The insufficiency,
the perceived insufficiency
of a mechanistic causal
in the narrow traditional sense.
- Narrow traditional sense, yeah.
- And so, you know,
but they make sense in response to that.
And so, what I wanna see us talking about
is the way in which to
push your point against
the epistemic accounts of
the conceptual further that,
I mean, I think you're conceding too
to epistemic conceptions of
the accounts of conceptualness
that we have to think about
concept use as practices.
And referring is something people do,
and they do it by
participating in practices
which enable us to then make sense of
and understand things like
referring beyond the light cone
or pointing to those aspects of the world
that we don't even have access to.
- Right.
- Didn't have access.
- No.
- Yeah.
- In a microbial world before that.
- I agree with you about
participating in these practices.
I guess, a lot of people
that I interact with
have an automatic causalistic
account of practice,
but practices are things that
involve bumping and shoving.
(Joseph laughs)
You know, that are subject
to one over R-squared laws
whatever, that preserve energy.
I mean, all of these kinds of things.
And I think,
so I remember asking,
did I mention this
question to Alonzo Church
in the talk yesterday?
Somebody...
- I don't think you did.
Yeah, I don't think.
- Anyway, ok.
So, Alonzo Church, when
he was still alive,
of course, was giving
this talk at Stanford,
and I was nervous and sat on my hands
and didn't think I was gonna say anything,
but my imagination often
unseats my pulley tests.
And I asked him after the talk,
"If I refer to the sun,
does it take eight minutes for
the sun to get referred to?"
- No.
- No, no, I know,
but I just wanna tell you that.
- Yeah.
- There's always, they
need your quotes there.
(Joseph laughs)
- There from both of them.
- You don't have to be
Alonzo Church to answer them.
- Yes.
(Joseph laughs)
- But,
but, two things.
First of all, Alonzo Church said,
"One, reference travels
at the speed of logic,"
which I think was a brilliant-
(Joseph laughs)
- Oh, brilliant.
- Even though I have no
idea what the hell it means.
(Joseph laughs)
But the thing is,
what matters to me is that
there is a property of the sun
that it was referred to.
It's not just a property of
us that we referred to it,
it's actually a property of the sun,
such that it was referred to
and that property obtains of the sun.
And now the relativity gets tricky.
Does it obtain of the sun right now?
I mean, is that even a coherent,
I have to defer it, Priya, here.
- Well, I dunno,
I think we could get into
a big controversy now.
I think I was,
I will escorted avoid this about
whether it's really a property of the sun.
I mean, I think the eight minutes
is not a property of the sun.
It's a-
- Well, no,
but it's got to be a property of the sun
in the sense that if I
think a thought about you,
that's about you,
that's gotta be a property of you
that you were thought about.
I think if you lose that,
you lose,
you know, we're in the
Trump Right-Wing Vortex.
(Joseph laughs)
- I don't quite think so.
I don't quite think so.
But let me,
I think Peter Morgan has
been very patiently waiting
with his question.
And, well, he has a couple of questions.
So he quotes, said by
Professor Rouse, in paraphrase,
"There is more in the world
than we can conceptualize.
There is that in the world
that we have so far conceptualized."
- Yeah.
- "How do we fix or place what we discover
and conceptualize tomorrow
into what we have so far conceptualized?
Are there ideas of distance
and betweenness as systematic indications
of how surprised we are by new discoveries
and conceptualizations?
And this also plays to what
Professor Rouse just said,
an ongoing discussion places
new utterances relative
to previous utterances,
which then can be adjudicated
and worked out systematically.
We have to allow a story
to continue, right?"
I mean, that's his sort of question.
- And, of course,
you know, the notion of distance here
is not spatial distance, right?
I mean, microbes that
were inconceivable to us,
except, you know,
in the sense of,
well, there might be such
things that we can't,
you know-
- An abstract way, right?
- Yeah, that's right.
In an abstract and empty way.
But that notion becomes concrete
and rich once you are
able to engage with that.
And, of course, you can
only do that by drawing on
and extending the resources,
including the material
practices that you already have.
I mean, this is one of the key features
that now thinking about
philosophy of scientific practice
that is,
you know, that the sciences exemplified,
taking what the relationships they uncover
and now turning those into resources
for bringing out other things.
That's part of how the sciences expand
you know, the realm of the conceptual.
And also, of course,
close off aspects,
things that it once seem
to make sense to talk about
and now only makes sense to talk about
in quotation marks, right?
You know, I-
- Right, I mean, and I think-
- Talking about when they
referred to phlogiston.
- Yeah, right.
- We no longer allow that.
- But, I think, right,
this gets at the heart of the fact
that scientific discovery
as we refer to it,
is inherently provisional.
I mean, that science itself is really,
our conceptual understanding
at any given time
is deeply provisional and that-
- It's also temporarily
extended in directions.
It's drawing on a history that
gives us open-ended resources
and allows it to be to
point beyond itself.
- Yeah.
- And in ways that,
and, you know, you talked earlier
about not being able to define concepts.
That's because the concepts
always involve more than
we're able to articulate
now in detail, right?
Typically, we have an opening
of a space of exploration
and the words we use.
I mean, think of the
history of the word gene.
- Oh, yeah.
- And the way it went from
a merely hypothetical entity
to physical,
to chemical, to structural,
to information theoretical in quotes,
to then being these complicated
regulatory networks.
- Right, then-
- Turned out to be also epigenetically.
- Yeah, it's become an
amalgam of everything
that it meant, right?
- Yeah.
- So, sort of...
So there-
- And you have
to think about it,
and of course, how the use of that word
is gonna get tied into practices
and what follows from it,
including, of course,
all the other non-scientific resonances.
The way in which is history
was connected to notion,
and especially the information notion of,
notions of an immaterial soul
that is at the heart of the body.
That that inferential
connection was so crucial
to the history of 20th century biology.
- There was a great
thing that John Hoagland
and I used to say that,
of course, there have
always been electrons,
but there have only always been
electrons since Rutherford.
(Joseph chuckles)
- Right, oh, so let's not
much as I am fascinated
by Bruno Latour,
let's not go down the
Latourian tunnel here with,
whether a pastour (laughs) whether...
- All right.
- Right, and the all-
- You know, Bruno tried to get
at some of that in one way,
but that's not quite
what Brian was saying.
- Right.
No, no, yeah, yeah.
But I think it-
- And it is closely connected
to this temporal externalism
that I'm emphasizing as well.
I mean....
- Right.
- You and John
and I actually have a lot of,
a lot in common on that and-
- Right, we do, we do.
That's why these disagreements
are so unnerving.
(Priya chuckles)
(Brian chuckles)
- Well, it's be,
you know, I mean, this was a lovely point
that Ian Hacking once made.
If two people disagree point by point
on a half a dozen issues
that they also take
to be really centrally important,
it means they agree on
almost everything else.
- Right, right.
- That very nicely characterizes
you and me. (chuckles)
- So I think before we close,
there's a request from
one of our guests, Steven,
who came up.
Would Professor Rouse be
willing to share his slides?
- Yes, happy to.
- And willing to try before,
yeah, and we can then add
that onto our video or-
- Yes, so should I send
that to Ty or to you?
- Yeah, could you please
go ahead to send it to Ty-
- I will do that.
- Thank you, thank you.
I'd like those, too.
- Yeah, so I think,
let me see if there is a quick question,
so that I...
I think, okay, there's a question,
it's not gonna be quick,
but we'll try to wrap it up soon.
"So listening to this
wonderful conversation,"
it's June Lao again,
"Wonders whether Brian and
Joe understand subjectivity,
scientific practices, human language,
et cetera, differently.
It seems that for Brian's subjectivity
in any sort of human doings
is as non-conceptual,
as the world is non-conceptual.
Similar to a digital circuit,
even with all the correct arrangement,
it still needs to be taken to be digital
for it to be digital.
But for Joe, this does not seem necessary.
Is this a fair understanding?"
- I agree with John,
so it's up to Joe.
- Well, subjectivity is
typically not one of my words.
(chuckles) Right?
I think it has too many
problematic connotations
which don't belong together.
Many of the things that people
talk about in those terms
are really important, okay?
And, you know,
the kinds of discovery of subjectivity,
whether it's in things like
impressionism in painting
or in the Interior Monologues of Joyce
and so forth, right?
Is itself a reconception,
is, you know,
in this sense, we now wanna say,
that before Joyce
there were interior
monologues (chuckles) right?
You didn't have the same
conception of interiority, right?
For it to show up that way.
So the kinds of things
people wanna talk about
in that way are important,
but we needed a better vocabulary,
and a better set of practices
for engaging with it.
Many of which have this kind
of character of subjectivity
as a kind of self-enclosure, right?
Which, I think, you know,
the subjective inner and the
causal interactive outer,
and that just seems to me
really distorting of all.
- Right.
- So that would be my answer.
- Okay, great.
Although we could keep going,
I think, in the interest
of our audience's stamina,
we should probably bring this to a close.
And I just wanted to say
thank you very much to Brian
and Joe for this wonderful exchange
and for clarifying a lot
of things for us about
the commonalities and the differences
in your conceptual
understanding of the world.
I'm gonna just, like,
(chuckles) enlarge it to.
- Yeah.
- Thank you all.
This has been a delight.
- Yeah, it's been a delight.
Thank you, especially Priya,
but also Brian and Ty and-
- Yes.
- Karen and Joe and everybody.
- Yeah, and I want to thank
the audience for being here
and participating and engaging with us.
So with this, we bring the Inference,
Understanding the Nature of
Inference Colloquium Series
to a close.
Thank you everyone,
and have a lovely evening.
Bye.